and often that can be
uh you can gain some squared from losing
that pawn but
when you lose one of the hanging pawns
often your opponent is the one
who gains a lot of squares so it's
always an interesting discussion there
um yeah 25
55 um no nationality or name
uh interesting to see
uh go gonna go for an old favorite of
mine here
the the the banker gambit
which i think has
kind of um faded away a little bit
um it's um
it's not a as popular as it was and
the way people usually play it is
without taking an a6 there
um and allowing a4 and then going queen
a5 later on followed by bishop takes a6
um i think both ways of playing are
okay but um when playing this opening
you got to be aware
that what is usually going to be better
[Music]
it's just a question of um whether you
can
sort of complicate the game and get a
playable position
rook b1 this is the old main line for
um for white and i have to say my
opponent is playing it quite
uh correctly uh playing rook b1
and uh bishop d2 is um is the
correct move order there and
uh it usually leads to some
some white advantage um yeah so here i
can go
knight g4 which is typical in 98
but now a4 may happen then it's been a
long time since i played these lines
um so i don't really know what to do
uh i think i played this move queen a3
though before
and uh sort of um
yeah obviously i'm not going to repeat
moves that's one of the points that
uh white sometimes has to make some kind
of concessions in order to get out of
that
repetition um
yeah we'll go knight c7 for the moment
i'm not worried about the pin
uh to my my queen uh now i'm a little
bit more worried
um because an ip5 not that worried
though
the question here though is how am i
creating counterplay
it's not it's not obvious
um
uh where is
my counterplay and my mind
okay we'll no probably we won't
okay let's um
bite in the sour grass as we say
norwegian and move the
queen away
um
probably queen a7 could happen next
i gotta i probably gotta play c4 at some
point
the good thing about my position though
is
while i am upon down and there's no
very obvious compensation for it my
structure
is very solid like the only weak point
in my structure
is potentially upon an e7
while d5
could be a little bit weak for white b3
could be a little bit weak
and if you move the pawn to e4 which is
very logical protecting the pawn
on d5 then there could some
could be some fairly weak squares
uh behind it especially d3
and the pawn on e4 could come under
attack as
as well so that is one of the points of
playing this opening that
you do get some um
some long-term structural compensation
for for the pawn you're down so
you shouldn't really panic if you cannot
find
immediate compensation and most of all
you should not listen to the computer
because the computer will always tell
you that white has a huge advantage
which could very well be true
um but
it also um
um it's it's a little bit
demoralizing i think when you're trying
to play this opening
bishop g5 is a bit surprising because i
can now
i can now win a pawn with bishop take c3
followed by bishop takes e2 question is
do i want it then rookie 1
knight takes d5 queen d2 my knight looks
look a little bit exposed
um probably i don't want to do that
it's it's also a common theme here
whether actually taking an e
seventh is a threat i believe it may not
be
uh bishop b7 i got rook e8 a5
deflecting the queen i got queen takes
a5 and the knight in c3 is hanging
if his bishop moves away to
uh to h4 uh then
g5 would trap the bishop so ian
in the end he decides that there's
nothing in particular to be um
to begin there okay
let me go queen before i assume bishop
d2 is going to happen
that i may go c4 it looks
risky um
but i may get away with it if bc4
queen c4
let's just think about this for for a
sec
if bc4 queen c4 rook b7 bishop b7
um i think
i think i'm happy um knight c5 is coming
next
don't think he can trap my queen with
the e4 bishop
f1 because i couldn't beat three there
later on
knight b5 is interesting
um then
cb3 rook b3 queen a4
seem to be doing well
okay i don't have time for this
obviously um and if
knight b5 cb3 queen
c7 i got queen a4
knight c3 pack i take on c7
and then i'll take an e2 some very
complicated lines here
um queen c6 as well
didn't think this was dangerous
queen a4 knight sees
seven might be very good for white but
i don't immediately see what's wrong
with queen c5 here
now i see what's wrong
now i do see what's wrong there's rook
c1
and i was thinking bishop takes b5 and
i'm completely fine but the rook and
on uh yeah the rook on
the square called uh b7 will be hanging
then
so that could mean that i'm in a world
of trouble then
after rook c1
um okay so
i think this means that i have to turn
to
plan b which is to
to try and hustle him in one way or
another
meaning either to fly him or
to somehow track him
and uh a church of rio
that's the name took some time for me to
oh that is so tricky that is so nasty
what he did here
yeah it's really nasty because you can
take on b7 now
okay i still have a hope though
it's not it's not that lost at
all rook takes b3 i take an e2 i should
have excellent drawing chances
uh knight f3 though yeah i'm not gonna
accept a draw
come on have you seen me play before i
don't accept like seth draws in worse
positions
either i'm going to get flagged or i'm
going to flag you
okay let's just exchange those make some
quick moves
and then it's going to be a flagorama
flagorama
sorry dude those are the rules
don't hate the player hate the game
actually i
i am the player and i am the rules
i i do make the rules so i am both the
players
i am why can't i speak i am both the
player
and the game
so you can hit both obviously
okay